foreign
[Music]
Selena Gomez and her little sister
Gracie live their best lives at the
Taylor Swift concert she's awesome she's
just there to have a good time I don't
think my sister overthinks anything and
that's what I love about it the only
murders in the building star hit up
Taylor's show in Arlington Texas on
Saturday night with her nine-year-old
sister the two were spotted in the crowd
of swifties dressed as Taylor Selena
channeling the singer's folklore era in
a cream cable knit cardigan and braids
Gracie rocking a purple dress and
ponytail a la Taylor speak now era and
cell she shared this clip on Instagram
dancing as her BFF sings her hit track
delicate
[Music]
but guys get this
things
yeah a little later in the show Taylor
gave Gracie her hat while singing 22.
and Gracie she gave Taylor a friendship
bracelet in exchange it was an amazing
experience fans snapped Selena dancing
her heart out
before hopping on a golf cart backstage
and on Sunday the triple threat shared
this pic of her sister flashing a heart
with her hands towards the stage writing
thank you bestie for having me and my
transport into your mystical
euphoric and Special World proud to know
you love you forever and always I love
it as for Gracie she's been her famous
sister's go-to plus one oh my goodness
yeah it's amazing Gracie joined cell on
the red carpet at the Golden Globes in
January and the dynamic duo have been
bringing some grade a sibling content to
tick tock
on Florida
not falling for that you embarrassed me
I just deleted the whole time
[Music]
last month cell summed it all up sharing
a series of snaps fishing with her
little sis writing grateful thankful and
blessed lady
[Music]